This solar eclipse that is happening today,
it is a sign from god.
The Bible tells us in the book of acts,
the second chapter,
it says, the sun shall turn into darkness and the moon into blood.
Before that great and notable day of the Lord. Come.
God is speaking.
God is beginning to show us things.
We have to receive what the Lord is saying.
God said in his word,
he said, when you begin to see the signs of the time,
know that the coming of the Lord is near.
God said to me today that we are living in the days of Noah.
The people are not receiving what is being said.
The people are not taking serious the coming of the Lord.
And this is why god is gonna come like a thief in the night.
Because they are not prepared.
Neither do they want to prepare.
So I pray that you receive these things that god is showing you.